[Music]
name another caste that is closer than
the Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants
we'll be hanging out and then realize oh
we we are the sister of the dropping pin
Blake Lively's shared a throwback pic
from May with Amber Tamblyn and Alexis
Bledel on Thursday and since America
Ferrera was not there
Blake photoshopped her in America
replied to the post writing Blake you're
like a professional portrait drawler I
was so confused about how I got into
that pic the quartet frequently hang out
together earlier this week America
joined Amber to spend time with her
daughter Marlo Leeanne Aguilera caught
up with America at nbc's TCA event
earlier this month where she gushed
about the friendship Blake recently had
said that sang friends with with all of
you guys has been such an inspiration in
her life what does it mean to you that
you guys have been able to stay friends
for so long in Hollywood well I don't
even really think of them as like my
actor friends I just think of them as my
friends and forget sometimes that we
were in a movie together and we'll be
hanging out and then realize oh we we
are the sisters of the Traveling Pants
that's where people are looking at it
you're friends until you all walk into a
restaurant and everyone goes bananas and
come up to you and take pictures yeah I
mean it's been I mean we made the first
movie 13 years ago so now they're just
my friends you know not venez venez not
quite as just friends status he's still
co-star co-star friend's dad
[Music]
you